want to focus on domestic policy rather
than what one of his aides has described
as the westminster soap op for getting
on to the matters of cost of living and
then i think the really key thing to
watch here is what does boris johnson
say about tax cuts ever since the vote
disgruntled conservative backbenchers
have come out and talked about the need
for tax cuts david davis in the times
newspaper today saying we are over
taxing our people to the tune of
billions of pounds at a time when they
can't afford it um
he's taken to his feet
and i'm sure the whole house will want
to join me in thanking the millions of
carers across the uk for all they do to
support their loved ones we've seen the
vital role carers have played in our
communities during the pandemic and we
all owe them a debt of gratitude
through our reforms on adult social care
this government is committed to
continuing to support carers and mr
speaker this morning i had meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today
today angela riedel
thank you very much mr speaker mayor
associate myself with the prime
minister's remarks about the importance
of carers in our country but this week's
events mr speaker have demonstrated just
how loathed this prime minister is
and that's only in his own party
[Applause]
so as his administration is too
distracted by its internal divisions to
deal with the challenges we face
can the prime minister explain if
148 of his own backbenchers don't trust
him why on earth should the country yes
[Applause]
well
i i thank i thank you the right
honourable lady very much for her
question and i can assure her that uh in
a long uh political career so far i have
of course picked up so
barely begun i of course picked up
political opponents all over the place
[Applause]
and that is because
it's and that is because uh this
government has done some very big and
very remarkable things which they did
not necessarily
approve of and what i want her to know
is that absolutely nothing and no one at
least of all her is going to stop us
with getting on uh
[Music]
thank you mr speaker
the whole house
will unite behind the prime minister
on his determination to hold ukrainian
war criminals to account
but is he aware that there are five
alleged rwandan war crimes perpetrators
living freely in the uk
who have been doing so now for 16 years
and have neither been extradited or put
before the british courts under our
existing laws as he prepares to go down
to the commonwealth heads of government
meeting in rwanda will he look carefully
at this issue because it is bound to be
raised with him and will he reassure the
house and the rwandan government he
takes these matters extremely seriously
and what has so far been justice
massively delayed for 16 years will not
be gratefully denied yeah
uh i thank my right honourable friend
for his question and he uh he raises an
issue uh on which uh the uk has
campaigned for a long time and no one no
country is more committed uh than we are
to bringing war criminals to justice i
know that my right honourable friend the
deputy prime minister uh has raised the
subject recently uh with the
international criminal court uh however
as he knows and i will certainly of
course study the case and and take it up
as appropriately it is the subject of an
ongoing uh investigation it would not be
appropriate for me to comment on it
further
we now come to the leader of the
opposition kissed up
thank you thank you mr speaker
i i couldn't make out whether that
introductory noise was cheers or booze
[Music]
the trouble is i don't know whether it's
directed at me or him
i joined the prime minister his comments
about carers
why did his culture secretary i think
hiding along the bench
say that
successive
successive
successive conservative governments
left our health service wanting and
inadequate
when the pandemic hit
[Music]
mr speaker everybody knows that when the
pandemic hit it was an entirely novel
it was an entirely novel virus for which
the whole world uh was unprepared and
nobody knew nobody at that stage nobody
knew how to test for it nobody knew what
the right uh quarantine rules should be
mr speaker but as it happened uh the uk
government and our amazing nhs
our amazing nhs produced not only
approved not only approved the first
vaccine anywhere in the world
we were the first to get it into
anybody's arms mr speaker
and we had the fastest rollout anywhere
in europe
none of which would have been possible
if we listened to him
i think the prime minister just agreed
with the culture secretary
perhaps she said it
i didn't deny it
perhaps perhaps she said it
because it's true
it starts with gps
people were unhappy with the service
they were getting before the pandemic
not enough gps too hard to get an
appointment
that's why he promised
6 000 new gps
but his health sector admits he won't
keep that promise
despite the hard work of doctors people
can't see a gp in person they're
unhappier than ever with gp services
if gp provision was wanting and
inadequate before the pandemic
what is it now
prime minister mrs big i'm afraid he's
simply wrong because uh what this uh
he's wrong about what we're doing
and of course miss we've got we've got
to clear the kobe backlogs and everybody
understands that everybody understands
everybody understands the pressure that
the nhs is under but they are responding
magnificently and i can tell him uh that
thanks to the investments that this
government has put in uh we now have 4
300 more doctors uh we have record
numbers we have record numbers in uh in
training uh and i told december we have
11 800 more nurses this year than last
year mr speaker and 72 000 72 000 in
training and that is because of the
investment that we put in which was
opposed by the party opposite and the
only reason we were able to make that
investment mr speaker is because we have
a strong and robust economy thanks
thanks to the decisions we took
today
mr speaker
of course he talks big but i've got a
letter here to the prime minister
from the honourable member from hereford
in south herefordshire
he said
this is you prime minister under you the
government seems to lack a sense of
mission
it has a large majority but no long-term
plan
mr speaker the prime minister's big plan
act is so tired that even once loyal mps
don't believe him
and it's not just waiting for a gp
it's waiting for all nhs treatment
take cancer
for over a decade waiting times for
cancer care have been going up
his solution was supposed to be
diagnostic hubs the health secretary has
been on a victory lap this week
but here's the rub prime minister
since they were opened last year
135 000 extra people are now waiting for
scans and tests
can he think of a better way
to describe soaring cancer waiting lists
than wanting an inadequate
[Music]
[Applause]
mr speaker it isn't it is entirely right
after the pandemic that people are now
coming forward to get their their cancer
tests and and we have we have actively
encouraged that and that is the that is
the right thing for people to do but as
a result of the community diagnostic
hubs that we are bringing in a hundred
of them across the country uh mr speaker
we are able to cut the times uh for
cancer diagnosis help people to get
their scans uh their tests faster and
above all we can do that mr speaker
because we're hiring more radiographers
we're hiring more nurses we're hiring
more professionals in our nhs because of
the investments that we made which as i
say the party of devon tragically
opposed
[Applause]
mr speaker the problem is
the cancer weights have been going up
for 10 years
and they're even higher now so blaming
the pandemic just won't wash
perhaps the culture secretary was
talking about the state of nhs buildings
before the pandemic the nao said they
were a risk to patients
the government's response
paint jobs and fix ups pretending that's
the same as building new hospitals
the treasure in the cabinet office
apparently don't think that the refurbs
are even going to be delivered
take university hospital north tees
the ceiling is falling in
the roof leaks
and staff have to hose down the pipes to
stop them freezing over
failure to fix wanting an inadequate nhs
buildings is putting patients at risk
isn't it prime minister
mr speaker this this line of uh
criticism is satirical coming
[Applause]
attacking our attacking our hospital
building program mr speaker
they were the authors of they were the
authors of the pfi scheme
what we're doing instead
is building 48 new hospitals yes we are
thanks to the thanks to the colossal the
biggest capital investment program in
the history of the nhs
from memory we put 33 billion pounds as
soon as we came in
then another 92 uh to cope with the
pandemic plus another 39 billion in the
health and care level
they opposed they opposed that funding
they opposed the health and care levels
they don't have a leg to stand on we're
building the foundations of rna this is
our health services future and they
should support it
[Music]
can i just say to both of you need to
come down and there's two over here as
well the four of you could have a very
nice cup of tea if you wish kiss armor
oh dear
prime minister
thirdly
climate
protect well
pretending
[Applause]
mr speaker
pretending no rules for brooke prime
minister he chumped us on pretending no
rules were broken didn't work
pretending the economy is booming didn't
work
and pretending to build 40 new hospitals
won't work either
they want him to change
but he can't
as always with this prime minister when
he's falling short he just changes the
rules and lowers the bar
in march he proposed changing the nhs
contract
he wants
to double the length of time patience
can be made to wait for surgery from one
year
to two years
on top of that he scrapped zero
tolerance of 12-hour weights at a e
24 hours of ine used to be a tv program
now it's his policy exactly
well it's healthy
and he he's telling all of that
order
mr cleverley
we've got a tea party gathering i'm sure
you don't want to be part of it i will
hear the question the problem is so do i
have a constituent
i wonder if i were you and i think one
or two of you might be going early well
everyone says luke i need to the
question in the same way i expect to
hear the answer so please kia stammer
mr speaker i bet they wish they were
this organized on monday
well mr speaker it's health week
and he's telling them he's going to turn
over a new leaf so why doesn't he start
by scrapping his plans to green light
wanting an inadequate nhs standards
[Applause]
this line of attack is not working mr
speaker but it's not it's not working
it's not working because
it's not working because they refuse to
approve
once again i think the two of you need
to calm down so please
we don't
know we don't want to see an empty front
vent prime minister
we've not only raised the standards
in the nhs and we're not only reducing
our waiting times for those who have had
to wait the longest mr speaker but what
we're doing more fundamentally is doing
what the people of this country can see
is simple common sense and that is using
our economic strength to invest in
doctors and nurses and get people on the
wards get people
giving people their scans and their
screens and their tests in a more timely
matter and getting uh and taking our nhs
forward we are on target mr speaker to
under thanks to this government to
recruit 50 000 more nurses
thanks to thanks to the investments i've
just got to repeat this because he
doesn't seem to have heard it so far
thanks to the investments that that
party opposed patrick can i explain why
they oppose them
[Applause]
mr speaker raising taxes because you
failed to grow the economy isn't a plan
for the nhs
and everyone sitting behind him knows it
members of this capital admit that
conservatives left our health system
wanting an inadequate when the pandemic
hit
he's been in power for three years and
things are getting worse not better
fewer gps more weights for cancer tests
building still crumbling and he's
changing the rules to cover up his
failure
and there is a real human pain as a
result
today i spoke to hamza semakula
hamza is 20 and he plays
semi-professional football for hendon he
tore his acl earlier this year
because of the two-year wait for surgery
he had to crowdfund for a private
operation
i also spoke to akshay patel
last year
his mother woke up
unable to breathe
akshay called 999
six times
in his last call he said
i rang an hour ago for an ambulance
as she had difficulty breathing
and now she's dead
even he must admit that akshay bina and
hamza deserve better than a wanting an
inadequate government
utterly unable
to improve our nhs
mr speaker i think everybody in the
house has uh sympathy with akshay and
the other constituents and their
families and the other constituents uh
that he that he mentions mr speaker and
uh and i i i i share uh their their
feelings but uh when you look at what
this government is doing uh the massive
and i i must say this to him uh we are
making colossal investments in our nhs
uh we are cutting waiting times uh we're
raising standards we're paying nurses
more we're supporting our fantastic nhs
and by the way he continually came to
the time let us remind him of this and
said that we had the worst covered
record in europe turned out to be
completely untrue and he still
he's still he still hasn't he still
hasn't refracted it
we're doing it mr speaker
we can make those investments because of
the strength of the uk economy because
of the fiscal firepower that we have to
deploy we have the lowest unemployment
now since 1974 and we are going to
continue to grow our economy for the
long term he asked about he asked about
the mission of this government mr
speaker it is to unite and level up
across our whole country to unleash
unleash the potential of our entire
country the biggest tutoring program in
history for young people raising
literacy and numeracy standards for 11
year olds from 65 adequacy to our 90
that is the highest objective i think a
government could achieve
expanding home ownership for millions of
people as my right honorable friend for
duluth and i will do
for millions of people who currently
don't have it cutting the costs
cutting the costs of business to make
this the enterprise center of europe
that is our vision
creating high-wage high-skill jobs for
this country and as for jobs i'm gonna
get on with mine and i hope he gets on
with his
[Applause]
but i didn't know you were so popular
come on
well we love honor changing the the
subject completely in north east
hertfordshire we're very concerned about
sewage overflows into our
precious
short stream
and
this is damaging to the floor and fauna
and also restricts the use of these
precious streams for leisure
the environment bill included some
important measures last year and i i
welcome the fact that the government has
consulted on its reduction plan for
storm overflows but
when would we expect to see some
meaningful improvements and some real
reductions in the amount of sewage going
into our rivers
yeah i i thank you very much and i share
his concern i can tell him our sewage
plants is the biggest investment on this
by any uh by any government we made it
clear that uh the water companies must
do more mr speaker and actually we
already are seeing improvements but uh
the regulator is ensuring that the water
companies do more to deliver on their
obligations we will not hesitate to take
further action as needed we now come to
the leader of the snp in blackford
thank you mr speaker can i associate
myself with the remarks of the prime
minister and the leader of the
opposition and supporting our
carers mr speaker
week after week
i've called on this prime minister to
resign
i've been met with a wall of noise from
the tory benches i thought they were
trying to
shout me down but all this time
[Applause]
but all this time mr speaker it turns
out that 41 of them have been cheering
me on
because
mr speaker let's be clear
at least the numbers don't lie
41
of his own mps have no confidence in him
66 of mps across the house don't support
him and 97
of scottish mps want the minister for
the union showing the door
we now have a
lame duck prime minister presiding over
a divided party
in a dis-united kingdom
how does the prime minister expect to
continue but even unionist leaders in
scotland won't back them
prime minister
gentlemen for his characteristic uh warm
words uh and just
and actually mr speaker i want to say
that the biggest and most powerful and
effective advocate of the united kingdom
over the last uh time that i've been in
it has been that man that
under his i don't know how long he's
going to last uh here as leader of the
snp
long may
long may he rest in place mrs b he is
the araldite that's keeping our kingdom
uh together right i think what he's
doing
well i can see i can say to the prime
minister
[Applause]
i can say to the prime minister that
i'll be standing shoulder to shoulder
with our first minister as we take our
country to independence
mr speaker
the prime minister is acting like monty
python's black knight running around
declaring it's just a flesh wound
no amount of delusion and denial will
save the prime minister from the truth
this story won't go away until he goes
away
for once in his life
he needs to wake up to reality
prime minister it's over it's done
the prime minister has no options left
but scotland does
scotland has the choice of an
independent future
[Music]
it's not just the prime minister that we
have zero confidence in it's a broken
westminster system that puts a man like
him in power exactly can he tell us
can the prime minister tell us how it is
democratic that scotland is stuck with a
prime minister we don't trust a
conservative party we don't support and
tony governments we haven't voted for
since 1955.
prime minister uh mr speaker we had a we
had a referendum as i've told the house
before uh in 2014 i think he should
respect the mandate of the of the people
and you know he keeps saying he keeps
saying that uh he well he he wants his
independence for his country our country
is independent
our country is independent
he then he tried 48 times to reverse it
to the the
opposition and the only way that
independence would ever be reversed is
we had the disaster mr speaker of a
labor snp coalition to take us back into
the eu
mr mike bay thank you mr speaker
earlier this week the prime minister
said you cannot spend your way out of
inflation you cannot tax your way into
growth we will cut the cost of
government here here i completely agree
so when can i suggest a strong start
that he scraps the inflated white
elephant that is hs2 saving
saving the government tens of billions
of pounds from a budget that is
spiraling out of control
prime minister
uh well i i i thank my right honourable
friend
in case you missed whatever what else i
said uh we're cutting taxes mr speaker
for everybody who pays national
insurance uh contributions by an average
of 330 pounds uh mr speaker just next
month and as for as for hs2 actually
what it will do is to have a long-term
growth and prosperity uh for the whole
of the country uh uniting and leveling
up deliver more revenues uh and and give
put us in a better position uh to cut
taxes in the future colomesela
today we hear reports that the prime
minister refused to consult the first
treasury council on his plans to rip up
uh the protocol i know this question
might be a bit redundant given he might
not be around very much longer
but given the prime minister's casual
record of casual law breaking will he
give a commitment to the people of
northern ireland that he will not break
international law anytime soon
prime minister mr speaker i can tell him
that
the reports that he's seen this morning
are not uh correct and i what i can also
tell him uh is that the most important
commitment that i think everybody in
this house uh has made is to the uh
the balance and symmetry of the belfast
good friday agreement uh that is that is
our our highest uh legal international
priority and that is what we must
deliver
dr james davis thank you mr speaker the
north wales mainline railway has seen
little investment for over a century in
practice this means that jobs at
manchester airport are poorly accessible
to many of my constituents with a
two-hour commute whereas a similar
journey in the southeast of the country
would be just 45 minutes so will my
right honourable friend ensure that the
north wales line features within the
updated rail network enhancements
pipeline at the decision to develop
stage
yes
i am a great enthusiast mr speaker for
this project uh we are looking at it and
i can tell him that the uh network rail
has received funding to carry the
account feasibility work uh on improving
north wells uh mainline uh journey times
and uh
travellers in north wales could have no
more uh effective advocate otherwise
friends
thank you mr speaker despite the prime
minister's promises of new hospitals and
more doctors and nurses
the bronte birth center at my local
hospital in batley and spen is
temporarily shut and is at risk of
permanent closure due to staff shortages
and lack of resources
the reality on the ground is that after
12 years of conservative mismanagement
the nhs is broken yeah so can the prime
minister explain to expectant parents in
my constituency why despite his promises
they are now forced to travel miles to
give birth and why his government voted
against an effective long-term workforce
plan for the nhs proposed by his right
honourable friend the member for
southwest surrey yeah
prime minister i thank her very much and
i i will certainly look into what's
happened the center that she mentions in
batman's but what i can tell her though
uh what i can tell her is that across
the country uh we are we are looking we
are investing massively in staff uh in
premises uh in technology in diagnostic
centers uh
i'm afraid for the party opposite to to
carp and to criticize is frankly absurd
because they voted against uh the health
and care levy that is putting billions
uh into our nhs and they need to sort
out their position either they support
it or they don't
thank you mr speaker would my right
animal friend join me in complimenting
bradford on becoming the city of culture
in 2025
but he also praised the team from durham
will give a fantastic representation of
what county durham had to offer bradford
must really be extraordinary to have
beaten us
and in 2025 durham will also celebrate
the bicentennial of the stock in the
dark passenger railway which will of
course distract people from bradford
i believe that my rideable friend is the
best person to lead on delivering living
up for the northeast
and to that end can he encourage
progress on the foreign development
reinvigorate the lean sideline
and help deliver a great county deal for
county durham
[Applause]
[Music]
i thank my my honorable friend and he
and i uh have campaigned on i've been
i've been following his campaign on this
for uh for a long time mr speaker uh i
i'm told that the department of
transport is currently reviewing the
business case for exactly uh what he uh
has just uh requested uh we're putting
the funding in uh mr speaker uh unlike
anything the party opposite ever could
have delivered richard johnson
thank you mr speaker in monday's
confidence vote the prime minister
secured the support of just two out of
scotland's 59 mps that means out of the
mass ranks of his scottish conservative
colleagues
he got as much support as there are
pandas in edinburgh zoo
the prime minister is an intelligent man
he must know that position's untenable
and if he's not going to do the decent
thing and resign as a prime minister
surely it's past time he wrote a letter
of resignation to himself to stand down
as the minister for the union
prime minister
i thank you very much uh mr speaker look
i really i really uh redirect the
honorable gentleman to uh what i said to
uh the right honourable gentleman uh my
friend uh the leader of the snp
uh because uh i i think the more the
more they campaign in the current
circumstances for breaking up our united
kingdom with all the strength and all
the merits uh that it has i think the
more damage they do to their own case
thanks smith thank you mr speaker
supporting adults with a variety of
mental health challenges learning
disabilities and conditions such as
dementia last week the prince's center
in princes risborough in my constituency
celebrated 10 years as an independent
daycare provider from my recent visit it
is quite clear what a happy welcoming
and supportive atmosphere has been
created for all service users so will my
right honourable friend the prime
minister join me in thanking and
congratulating the manager kim chalena
her whole team of staff volunteers and
trustees for delivering this first class
service and as check as is but a hop
skip and a jump from princess risper
would he deliver those congratulations
in person all right
uh well i i i thank my honourable friend
who is many other distinctions i think
my mp uh and uh i joined i also joined
him in thanking uh the entire team at
the princess uh center for everything
that they do and i will certainly keep
his kind invitation in mind absolutely
mr speaker
i'd have more sympathy for the words get
to
get on with the job
if it actually started in the first
place
[Laughter]
two weeks ago
two weeks ago the prime minister told
the house
to the best of my knowledge everybody is
getting their passport within four to
six weeks
however the possible office is currently
quoting a 10-week service time
with many of my constituents
waiting well over that period
cancelled summer trips
could cost families over 1 billion
pounds
does the prime minister accept
that the passport of his backlog is
placing additional pressure on families
already struggling with the cost of
living crisis
[Applause]
actually mr speaker what uh
we're doing is
91
are getting their passport within six
weeks i can tell him mr speaker
and we are putting hundreds and hundreds
more staff into the passport office
and and this the strength of demand by
the way is a sign of the robustness of
the economy because everybody uh is
frankly wanting to go home then and and
quite right too mr speaker but when it
comes to travel chaos when it comes to
trouble chaos have we heard any
condemnation yet from the from the from
the opposition from the rmt and their
reckless and wanton strike what about
that you mr speaker as my right
honourable friend knows rochester strude
is facing unrealistic housing targets
putting pressure on the council to bring
forward a local plan that will close
successful working docks and the loss of
beloved open spaces such as dean gate
ridge all in the name of meeting an
arbitrary target can my right honourable
friend assure my constituents who are
facing this level of overdevelopment
that there will be greater flexibility
on housing numbers so that the council
can produce a local plan that delivers
the appropriate housing but protects
important sites like these yeah
i i thank my uh my old friend and she
speaks i know uh for for for colleagues
up and down uh the country we want to
make sure that councils are able uh to
build uh in the right place and uh
sensitively to uh to local needs and
that is what uh we insist on uh but i
just want to make it one thing
absolutely part of the the merit the
genius of leveling up mr speaker is that
it will encourage us uh to take some of
the pressure some of the heat out of uh
the southeast of england which has been
overburdened uh for decades and we can
do it
thank you mr speaker my constituent mark
is trying to sponsor two sisters from
ukraine to come to the uk these two
sisters were housed in dangerous
temporary accommodation in montenegro
for several weeks while the uk home
office refused to process the
application of the younger sister
because she's 13 and traveling without
her parents even though she had her 18
year old sister with her the 18 year old
sister is now in london and the 13 year
old sister has been sent back to her
hometown in ukraine which is under siege
can i ask the prime minister can he tell
you hand on heart does he think sending
vulnerable children back to a war zone
is the right policy
well mr speaker of course i i understand
her indignation about the case that she
uh that she mentions and i know that my
radar from the home secretary will be i
will be looking into it but i have to
say i do think the record of this
country uh in processing so far i think
well over a hundred thousand uh 120 000
uh visas for ukrainians is is very
creditable i thank all the staff uh
who've been involved in that effort
mr speaker
friends will remember that in march i
asked him about increased research
funding for aortic dissection as called
for by the aortic dissection charitable
trust
will the prime minister update me on the
progress with this will he also
recognize the immense value of the
patient awareness videos that have been
produced by
tadct
featuring
whispering bob harris survivors
relatives of patients to help those
going through this awful condition for
the first time
prime minister uh well i thank my
honourable friend for her fantastic work
on this and i know uh the personal
circumstances that uh that uh give her
understanding of this uh of this
campaign i can i can tell her that uh
the national institute for health
research is uh looking at what more we
can do uh to support research on aortic
dissection i know that as she's meeting
my writable friend uh the health
secretary shortly after a kid
thank you mr speaker the ukrainian
freedom orchestra and the key symphony
orchestra due to visit the uk this
summer to perform at the bbc proms the
edinburgh festival and other venues
but while other european countries are
waiving their visas to get to the uk the
musicians are facing both visa delays
and prohibitive visa costs
18 000 and 10 000 respectively
we should be doing all we can to support
these ukrainian musicians yeah yeah so
will the prime minister match our
european neighbors and enable these
ukrainian artists to tour to the uk this
year by expediting their visa
applications and waiving the visa fees
[Applause]
she i think she needs to bring the
particular case to uh to my right
honorable friend but i can tell i can't
i can tell i can tell the house and what
they know and i know that many
honourable members by the way are
showing a lead uh by having a ukrainians
to stay in their own homes and i thank
all honourable members to do that
thanks to the scheme that the uk
government has put in place i think we
should be very proud of what we're doing
mr speaker the prime minister knows from
his visits to record cleveland that we
enjoy miles of beautiful uninterrupted
course line however since october last
year we've seen thousands of dead and
dying crustaceans wash ashore jeffrey
construct conducted an investigation
into this which led to the theory of
algal bloom being the primary cause for
these deaths however this report does
nothing to support the fishermen left
devastated by this freak event through
norfolk they're on will the prime
minister look at how he could support
this vital industry to get them back on
their feet
minister i i know
my honorable friend and i were walking
together on the the seafront uh in red
car when uh when i was etm eating a
lemon top actually mr speaker uh when
somebody raised this very point uh with
us and uh and i can tell him uh that
we've ruled out uh chemical pollution uh
mr speaker but we are we are looking at
uh we are making another 100 million
pounds of investment uh including uh in
communities such as his and working with
uh the fishing industry to help them uh
recover from this problem final question
kenny mccaskill yeah the poorest in this
country currently pay the highest fuel
costs through pre-payment meters that
have higher standing charges and higher
tariffs
belgium ensures a social tariff for the
poorest and most vulnerable
as the perversion pernicious euphemism
of self-disconnection enters the lexicon
when in fact it's a politically imposed
choice not something chosen by
individuals is it not time that we
provided a social tariff and ended the
injustice of prepayment meters prime
minister
uh i i thank him mr speaker i can i can
tell him that what we're uh doing in the
uh immediate uh what we're doing right
right now
is helping uh eight million
families eight million households across
the country with twelve hundred pounds
of support a four hundred three three
next three hundred pounds uh for
pensioners here in receipt of the cold
weather payment plus uh 400 pounds mr
speaker uh for every household in the
country and and that is the support that
we're giving right now and to help
people with the cost of of energy and uh
the only reason we can do it as i've as
i've said before to the house is because
of the strength of the economy uh and
because of the the the brave tough calls
that we got right during the candidate
right
that is the end of prime minister's
questions uh pretty low-key at pmqs uh
it seems that most of the people who've
been watching it would agree analysts uh
we're going to get some reaction from
our political editor beth rigby in a
moment but first let me just bring you a
reminder of the breaking news this hour
and that is that one person is dead
eight have been injured after a driver
hit a number of pedestrians and people
in cafes in berlin
a spokesman for berlin police has told
sky news that the driver is apparently a
29 year old man with dual german
armenian citizenship you can see that is
the car that crashed into the front of a
shop after mounting the pavement and
then rejoining the road and then once
again mounting the pavement we've been
told from the german fire brigade that
of the eight injured five of them are
seriously injured with life-threatening
injuries
well let's get more reaction now on
prime minister's questions uh beth rigby
is here uh beth what did you make of it
well it was it was a bit flat wasn't
jamie we were saying that as it as it
was going on look i think that there was
an attempt by kirsten were there to try
and get back to policy issues the nhs
has long been labour's biggest calling
card with voters boris johnson famously
when he announced that social care
package and that extra 12 billion for
the nhs funded through tax rises that
they've partially now reversed he sort
of stood on a pager and said we are the
party of the nhs now and kirsten were
quite consistent talking about waiting
times for ambulances cancer-less waiting
times uh
but you know poorly uh poorly um
repaired buildings really trying to be
consistent on
on that matter but actually for boris
johnson the politics of all of that was
he batted that all away and then he
ended with that stump speech as i would
said where he sort of reminded his
colleagues of all his greatest hits
talking about the economy and low
unemployment and some of the youth
employment programs his governments
introduced and he was very clear at the
end of that he said uh as far as jobs go
i'm going to get on with mine and i hope
he
kissed armor gets on with his i mean the
the sort of most interesting personal
attack and and we had a little laugh
about it because i think we're both
monty python fans and i remember
watching this as a kid with my parents
was was actually in blackford when he
said um
he said he likened the prime minister to
the black knight running about saying
it's just a flesh room and where his
arms were hanging off
um
i mean that was the kind of kind of
moment of a personal attack on johnson
in terms of what's happened in the past
week but i wonder for labour now that
given how damaged he's already been by
the
uh revolt on his own benches kierstama
they're clearly taking a judgment that
he doesn't want to need to
issue more personal attacks on the prime
minister i mean detractors from
kierstarma might say or some of his
benches might say hang on a minute the
guys just lost a confidence vote and you
haven't really
landed a blow on him today i imagine
that stammers
approach there is what he's trying to do
now is get back onto policy issues to
say to the public look there's a view of
this uh character of the prime minister
which kirsten has been very critical of
uh and that's been borne out by the
rebellion on his own benches and now
let's get back on to to policy issues
and talk about what people are unhappy
about i mean if you ask any conservative
mp
that the issue of waiting lists on the
nhs is is clearly a massive problem for
them running in
to millions the nhs is not a huge drone
of course there is a post pandemic
hangover for the nhs and that issue of
gp surgery is the issue of passports
there's lots of things in government now
that the opposition are going to drill
in on and say look this guy this prime
minister is just not running your
government in the way it should be run
and what debaters care about they really
care about the nhs and of course the
cost of living so these are the sort of
policy problems he's got
we said it was it was a bit like luster
but there was a slightly fire exchange
from the beginning so let's just listen
again to that
they oppose the health and care of you
they don't have a leg to stand on we're
building the foundations of rna this is
our health services future and they
should support it
oh dear
prime minister
[Applause]
[Music]
climate
protect well
pretending
[Applause]
mr speaker
pretending no rules for brooke prime
minister he chumped us on pretending no
rules were broken didn't work
pretending the economy is booming didn't
work
and pretending to build 40 new hospitals
won't work either
they want him to change
but he can't
as always with this prime minister
when he's falling short he just changes
the rules and lowers the bar he asked
about he asked about the mission of this
government mr speaker it is to unite and
level up across our whole country to
unleash unleash the potential of our
entire country the biggest tutoring
program in history for young people
raising literacy and numeracy standards
for 11 year olds from 65 adequacy to our
90 that is the highest objective i think
a government could achieve
expanding home ownership for millions of
people as my right honorable friend for
duluth and i will do
for millions of people who currently
don't have it cutting the costs
cutting the costs of business to make
this the enterprise center of europe
that is our vision
creating high-wage high-skill jobs for
this country and as for jobs i'm gonna
get on with mine and i hope he gets on
with his
yeah that that that the pm stump speech
and really although he's facing kirsten
there he's talking to his back benches
he's saying these aren't things we have
done and i am not going anywhere and and
i think the prime minister there
actually today given the week he's had i
mean it must be deeply uncomfortable for
any leader to see four out of his 10 mps
say he wants him gone but he is doing
what he typically typically does he's
coming out and he's fighting and i think
the thing that we will be interested in
watching in the coming weeks and days is
how does he try and reboot his
leadership now there's a housing speech
coming up will there be further tax cuts
will uh the chancellor uh do a speech on
cutting regulations that's something
else we've heard about will the prime
minister do a reshuffle will he
introduce uh legislation around the
northern ireland protocol to try and
unblock some of that but that could also
prove divisive in his party so really
now
for all of the confidence that the prime
minister showed that at the dispatch box
today sitting behind him are 148 mps who
do not think he should remain in office
and and once that happens to you for all
the confidence and display of confidence
that you show you have a a deep problem
i was interested though that kierstama
didn't seem to go on the attacks in the
way he has in the past and it makes me
wonder whether labour are now making the
calculation that a wounded prime
minister
uh in power with this going on this
civil war in the conservative party
going from months and months and months
is better actually
for labour than having a change of
leadership and a new energization of the
concern because
he's so different to kirsten that there
is clear water between them isn't that
and and whoever replaces him may not be
but
no i mean kierstama really
he also is struggling to make an impact
with voters you know he he needs to
capitalize on the weaknesses of of the
prime minister and he's tried to step
the broad brush strokes of that but
actually i think peter mandelson who was
so instrumental in in the blair brown
years uh said today you know kierstarma
really needs to now set out his policy
stall what is he about beyond not being
jeremy corbyn and i think actually him
talking about the nhs today was a sign
of where labour are now moving which is
picking i imagine policy areas that they
really think that they can hammer the
conservatives on because maybe the
judgment is made for now on boris
johnson's character amongst the public
uh but what about policies kirsten
really needs to try and cut through
and show voters why labour would be
worth voting for
okay bet thanks very much good to see
you
well you are watching sky news today
coming up we're going to bring you more
from berlin where one person has died
and five others have life-threatening
injuries after a man drove a car through
a crowd in berlin we'll bring you the
very latest updates
[Music]
they've pushed the protesters further
back here there's around two or three
hundred still remaining
i'm dan whitehead and i'm sky news's
west of england correspondent
[Music]
this fan goes on to the streets of
plymouth seven days a week 365 days a
year these facilities are at the moment
a lifesaver
[Music]
fishing communities to bustling cities
we spend every day reporting from across
the region hearing from people who have
real stories
i have nowhere to live for
about three or four months
there are still people inside the
properties here
they're coming from the epicentre of
what is now a global health pandemic
we were seeing and speaking to young
women who were selling themselves right
on the high street it was desperately
sad and the fact it was happening right
in the heart of this community
brexit these oysters were being exported
to the eu but the trade stopped
overnight
what's your feeling about the future
then
blake
might all be
finished i don't know
[Applause]
[Music]
you